Keanu Reeves has found his happy place
with a long time love Alexandra Grant I
can't connect with someone like this the
John Wick star recently opened up for
people's one last thing series answering
questions about different moments in his
life like the last time he danced or the
last time he watched the sunrise you
know when you love something you always
have a little bit more but one
particular answer has fans really
swooning the question when was your last
moment of bliss his response a couple of
days ago with my honey we were in bed we
were connected we were smiling and
laughing and giggling feeling great it
was just really nice to be together yeah
it's going great well it's unclear when
the lovebirds first met they've
reportedly been together since 2011 when
they collaborated on his book owed to
happiness a picture book for adults
featuring drawings by Alexandra it's
good storytelling I've always been
someone who responds to those kinds of
stories
in 2016 they worked together for a
second time on his book shadows and
posed together on the red carpet during
art basil in Switzerland the two started
their own book publishing company in
2017 and in March 2020 Alexandra
explained to Vogue UK that she first
made Ode to happiness as a surprise gift
for her man before they decided to
publish it all our friends sitting in
the room got the giggles when I gave it
to him they said please publish it so
that's how we got into publishing but it
was this red carpet moment in 2019 that
nearly broke the internet when Keanu and
Alexandra made their love public holding
hands at the LACMA art and film Gala
when Vogue UK asked Alexandra in 2020 if
they were thinking about saying I do she
explained love at every level is deeply
important to my identity how's that for
dodging the question
[Music]
thank you